what's up guys my name is channel we
made a game I want you to play it so a
couple of weekends ago was London dare
53 for those of you who don't know
ldjam.com this is a like a 48 to 72 hour
game Jam you can make a game by yourself
in 48 hours or with a team in three days
we as a studio have done three of these
in the last like year and a half and
we've basically used them as an
opportunity to test out Hazel to use
Hazel to actually make and ship games
and it's been quite a fun time the first
game we made was Forest which was we
don't talk about that game then we made
dichotomy which I thought was pretty
cool that was the last game that we made
was like a puzzle game you jump around
and stuff and this time around we made
Saving Captain Chino
um an interesting title to a game the
theme this time was delivery which
personally I didn't really like too much
and so we made a game about delivering
coffee in a war zone and I threw in some
like randomly generated hexagonal tiled
Worlds the game is completely free of
course to download and play the link
will be in the description below it's on
our hio page I've patched it a little
bit post launch to add compatibility to
some more GPU drivers and stuff so
hopefully hopefully it'll work for you
and not crash uh and so I thought it
would be fun
um yeah you can see there's been some
fixes I thought it would be fun to just
play it because I don't think the past
two games that we've made uh forest or
dichotomy I have actually played like as
in front of you guys so I thought I'd
make a video and play it basically
that's what uh that's what this video is
so let's hit download now
um
let's download it okay so once you
download it and unzip it you'll see
these three files the launcher is the
thing we care about let's open that
don't worry about this uh when it's
protected your PC please uh and here we
have the launcher so this launcher just
lets you pick like all of your graphics
settings
um we don't like it was a bit of a chore
to go through every resolution that your
display supports and printed here so we
have this render scale instead it's
basically like your resolutions if you
don't want to if you want to play it
like in full screen but you want to play
it half res you can just do like that I
mean that'll be half resin each uh in
width and height but basically if you're
really really struggling with
performance drop this down but otherwise
I would just uh you know by default I
think it'll be on the max settings which
is what this is
um so you might have to drop these
depending on your system let's just hit
play all right so
uh we have play game and controls arrows
and select so controls will just kind of
tell you what the controls are recommend
you read this first also in the readme
if you want to kind of refer to that
which does actually support controllers
as well so if you have a controller you
can just plug that in at any point and
play with a controller um but I'll kind
of guide you guys through the game
anyway so let's just go to play game and
here we are
okay so the world as I mentioned is
randomly generated
um and then there's uh attention Captain
Chino over there so let's read it the
general has ordered a coffee and needs
its stat pressing press tab to open your
compass here it is so
um I saw a few comments being like which
way do I go
um like I don't know if you guys have
seen compasses before but like I mean
you know red is usually North so I would
assume you could go that way but
apparently that wasn't obvious
um so I'm sorry if I ruined your day but
uh press tab to open your compass use it
to navigate pick up the General's coffee
order from the coffee tent and bring it
to him press that is continue yes it's
dangerous but we can't win this war
without coffee you'll have to protect
the coffee at all costs and if you spill
it well just make sure you go back and
get a fresh one for the general between
you and me here's a bit of a coffee nut
or should I say Bean ha
I write that make the delivery cabin
we're counting on you one of the jokes
was like Captain cappuccino like that's
why it's Saving Captain Gino well save
it saving is in like Saving Private Ryan
obviously but saving uh Captain chinos
having cappuccino you know very funny
we're counting on you assistant to the
general and that's a bit of an office
reference as well assistant to the
general
um press enter to close all right cool
so
uh we basically follow this Compass you
can't use it all the time by the way it
has a cool down I hope this is recording
uh smoothly by the way I always I'd
never trust OBS maybe I should switch it
to game view I'll try that actually just
in case okay I've switched OBS to game
view so I don't know if it's going to be
any uh better but
it is what it is okay so yeah we follow
the compass we get in here
um there's a gun here so it says in the
bottom left corner grab assault rifle
and then we also have the coffee so it
doesn't really matter what order we grab
them in we grab them now we have a gun
with a flashlight which casts shadows as
well which is nice pretty cool
um and then you can shoot with the left
Mouse button I recommend you don't shoot
immediately though because you have a
finite amount of ammo that appears in
the bottom left when you shoot and uh
actually if you run out of ammo at this
stage in the game you basically have to
restart like there's nothing you can
basically do uh because you can't kill
enemies without a gun and you can't get
more ammo
without killing enemies so yeah a bit of
a loophole but it is what it is all
right so
um yeah the world is randomly generated
um
and uh the where you have to go is also
randomly generated so sometimes you'll
get really lucky and you'll just like
the General's tent will be very close
sometimes it will be very fast so you
have to kind of be careful and you can
see I can't keep using my compass
because it
it uh doesn't always open so there's a
bit of a cool down okay that was really
easy so there we go I can basically
deliver the coffee uh by pressing q and
guess what I just won so let's play that
again again look at this randomly
generated World maybe this will be
harder this time
um the you can see the nice Reflections
from the water as well they're just
screen space Reflections so don't get
too excited but they do look quite nice
um there we go you can see that mountain
if you don't look down uh let's go past
these messages let's go to this tent
again which this is also in a randomly
generated place
um
so we'll pick up this stuff and let's
see if this will be harder now
let's go this way
all right so you can see those red
lights off into the distance they look
like enemies so this is basically how
you fight enemies uh you can right click
and fire now if you hold right click
you'll kind of zoom in a bit and you'll
basically lock on to the Target so it's
very like it's basically kind of like an
Aimbot if you hit fire like this you
will not
um uh obviously lock on to anyone so you
can kind of free file like that as well
uh
but if you right click you'll kind of
lock on to the nearest anime that you're
facing towards and also time slows down
so you can see I'm jumping in like slow
motion so it's kind of a cool slo-mo
effect as well uh okay let's pick up
this gun
this is a sniper rifle but I guess I'll
pick it up yeah unfortunately if you
pick up the gun it like destroys the
other gun which probably we should fix
but
yeah
this gun should have a longer range but
oh
um I want to quickly yeah as you can see
it's getting a little bit overwhelming
let me pick up this shotgun because
that'll be easier so you can see it's
kind of like with right click it's quite
easy oh no I put down my coffee let's
grab it again
um and then as you take damage as well
I'm probably doing a very bad job of
explaining this but you can see the
coffee is actually spilling out like if
you look at that at the moment there's
like about half left every time you get
shot you don't actually take damage the
coffee takes damage so you really have
to protect that coffee which you can
just put it down on the ground and fight
enemies that's a that's a valid strategy
another valid strategy is to basically
like nothing is stopping you from like
if you know the General's tent is in
that direction I think if you put the
coffee down it will guide you to the
coffee
right let me just wait for my compass to
come back yeah so you can see it's
guiding me to that coffee
um but if I pick it up I can see like
where I'm supposed to go as far as like
the General's tent goes
so that way right
um so what I could do is I could
actually leave the coffee here or even
just leave it at the coffee tent not
pick it up yet once I know where the
General's tent is and just clear the way
because what will happen is enemies only
spawn when you like kind of uncover a
new chunk because the way that the world
generation works is like when you
approach like the border of a chunk it
generates more chunks in the direction
you're heading in and thus that has a
chance to obviously support enemies
spawn enemies and the more enemies the
the further you are from like you know
the coffee tent the more enemies will
actually spawn
um so it gets kind of progressively
harder but uh because they don't respawn
and chunks you've already been to as
long as you don't explore like new
places
oh I'm out of ammo oh this is this is a
disaster I might actually lose I did
lose my coffee's gone
Oh see it does get hard okay so yeah so
what I could do is I know it was roughly
this way I think so what I could do is
do a little bit of scouting because I
can't die right
um I could do a little bit of scouting
here and just clear the way
which I'm hoping
yeah see the right click option is uh
there should be an achievement oh my
gosh look how many there are there
should be an option to um or like an
achievement for beating this game
without trying to hit fire
uh needs to pick up but see I can't
actually oh yeah also that happens
because of pedophysics
um
yeah see I can just mow them down
with hip firing so but I was saying
there should be an achievement to to
beat the game without uh
you know
um using the right click kind of firing
mode because that's basically an Aimbot
um but that being said since you can't
die there's nothing it'd be easy to get
that achievement I can't believe there's
so many so see sometimes it will be
really hard because what will happen is
if the General's tent is
I got the shotgun here if the General's
tent is um
damn
if the General's tent is far away then
you're gonna get like wrecked
as you can see
all right lots of guns though that's
good so what am I on here I got a sniper
I don't want a sniper I think like the
shotgun's pretty good the assault rifle
does the least damage but you can just
kind of spray it as I was doing and so I
think it's probably the one of the
better better things to use I actually
don't know if I'm heading in the right
direction though by the way and the
world uh is quite large it's like 50 by
50 chunks and each chunk is 16 by 16
tiles yes it is good getting them onto a
flat surface if we had more time I would
have made the water swimmable but we ran
out of time
Loosely considering like just working on
this game for fun outside of the jam
um because it is kind of fun and maybe
if it had more features it would be even
better and I really like the hexagonal
world to be honest like I think that's
really cool
um I don't know there's something about
these hexagons it's just a cool
aesthetic I really like it okay I
suppose we should run back so we
shouldn't really encounter any enemies
let me just maybe pick up a fresh
assault rifle with more ammo
um that ammo counter in the bottom left
by the way that only shows like it's
limited to like 10 Max bullets so if you
have more than that it'll just cap it at
10 I think it's 10.
um
so
uh that's why like it'll only show you
less if you actually have less
there was sprinting initially but we
decided to cut that out because it was a
bit too easy
okay so I can see that see that light
off into the distance
that's the um that's the coffee tent so
we'll go back to the coffee tent
by the way if you want to see oh there's
two coffees here that is interesting why
they're two coffees that must be a bug
um if you want to see the performance
control F3 by the way we'll show you
stats there's some in the top right
corner which you probably can't see
because the face cam but remember I'll
show you briefly and then the bottom
right as well so that's kind of uh
the performance is pretty much like
fairly GPU limited because there's all
these effects going on and we need to
optimize our GPU rendering
all right so I don't know how many
enemies will encounter here but I also
don't know how far that General's tent
is it could be very far
so let's see if we can make it is
actually quite a long session especially
uh if you compare that to the previous
oh no
I'm actually gonna try and fight here
because I don't want to die
um
because yeah because the first run was
so quick
all right here we go
so you kind of aim without and I guess
that I don't think they even fighting me
because see that coffee looks very full
I found it this is it this is the
General's tent see so the kind of
clearing the way was good but look how
many there are now
I could probably just run in there but
I'm not going to risk it
oh I'm out of ammo I'm out of ammo
what's that is that a shotgun luckily
yes oh I buried I didn't really spill
any coffee oh that was close that felt a
lot more dangerous than it was
um all right and I think that's it this
is the general so you basically walk up
here into the tent and then you press Q
to drop which is what the instructions
said and voila you have won the game I
want to try one more time just to see
what else we get because yeah you can
see the snow as well
um this has been a nice the random
generator has been nice to me because
it's showing me different Wells every
time but um yeah
you can see there's some snowy worlds uh
sometimes you can get like more flat
like this is pretty flat as you can see
um and she can get more kind of hilly
mountainous worlds and
uh but basically there's only like four
different tiles there's no uh grass sand
and water and water is basically solid
so yeah
um but yeah that's the game I hope you
guys will give it a go and that you
enjoy playing it of course there's
something we put together in three days
nothing too fancy uh the whole thing was
live streamed as well here on YouTube so
you can just I'll leave a link in the
description below but the whole team so
me Tim and Peter we all live streamed on
YouTube so you can see all the vods and
kind of see how this game came together
over the three days and if you're
interested in seeing some kind of like
technical breakdown of how we put it
together or it's behind the scenes or
whatever maybe I can talk a bit about
how Hazel kind of I guess works with
this game or whatever let me know in the
comments Below have a great rest of your
day and I'll see you next time goodbye